my name is Maksim Morozov I'm chief
executive of intelligence retail company
so we're a technology company from
Eastern Europe we have a presence in
Finland and Russia there's a big
challenge still in in brick-and-mortar
retail we are all shoppers right and
when we visit stores we expect a
well-organized shelf so it means that
all the products should be at the shelf
so prices should be correct so
promotions are not outdated and that's a
big problem number one problem for
retail now it costs more than 500
billion every year if the product is
missing for example if the product is
out of shelf and you don't know it every
minute you lose money that's what we try
to fix it means that we need more
recognition power on our servers for
example if the customer starts in one
region and they start to send us like
100,000 follows per month they can
easily roll out the solution to to other
countries to other regions and increase
in this number up to some Millions we
now know that we can support easily any
projects any size of the customer and we
can easily scale rollout to other
countries and other regions we are not
afraid now if the customer send us you
know ten millions photos to be
recognized we know that infrastructure
is allows us to do and end to scale our
recognition power we need a reliable
infrastructure and big data solutions
that's why we at the end we chose IBM